you know and that had to be hard for you
i mean i know obviously
but you know because i read the quote
i'm sure you've you've heard it but it's
like
you know your dad was quoted as and this
wasn't that long ago right
i mean 2017 i never had a relationship
with katie i wasn't her father
biologically
uh you know biologically i was but i
didn't raise her he said he was proud of
you and you were so talented
was it hard to hear that or were um
no i mean look that was the truth i
chose not and this is the truth
my father you know
he had demons as we all do
um and you know i think that
fame and as child fame
i mean i've been in therapy my whole
life thank you
good for you dr shirley um
i think it can really mess you up and i
think
i chose at some point you know later
once i was
20 four
i think maybe 25
it just wasn't healthy for me because
you know he was struggling with
you know alcohol and and it just
i chose at some point that it wasn't
you know it wasn't it wasn't healthy and
when he was in the hospital and i had
heard
that he was in i'm now going off track
no no you're not
you're not going off track you're just
talking ultimately about
you know like when he said these nice
things about you and then of course
you know it's hard to deal with you know
the loss of him but you you
i guess you're saying you heard that he
was in the hospital yeah so
he had said these things to me but what
that didn't like
it didn't hurt me that he said that i
mean it was true but in one point we
were really close friends when i was
younger
you know he was more like my best friend
i remember i would talk to him every
night for hours
um and but and that was years ago but
anyway so when
he went i i when he was in the hospital
i went
and my uncle was there and and
he was in a coma already and it was such
a beautiful
moment my uncles were there my brother
was there and
we all were surrounding him you know
together and
and he passed and
it was it's hard to
it's hard to describe it because
i was so estranged from them not my
brother
and not my uncles but
him for about seven years and i
i think it was like almost like a
forgiveness
is what it was like for all of us
because i you know i think he had
difficulties with my uncles and i
certainly think you know with my brother
at times i think it was just this moment
of
i i don't know like yeah i guess like a
relief like he could be in peace
you know um